I didn't know Ryan philippi stars in the
upcoming thriller a wish upon alongside
Joey King out July 14 obviously in real
life you have a 17 year old daughter and
in this movie you play a dad to a 17
year old daughter so did you pull from
that relationship with Ava and of course
yeah she and Joey are exactly the same
age and there's a lot of similarities
that both highly intelligent super funny
you know and so I think it also made it
that much more comfortable for Joey and
I the fact that I have that experience
and I'm still very much in tune with
what the youth is about today because
you have to be if you're a parent of
teenagers you know especially with the
social media aspect I love all of it and
our film sort of touches on some of
those themes and bullying my bad
do you worry about that as a dad your
kids getting bullied online at all I
think it's something that you think
about luckily my kids haven't dealt with
that I think they know friends who have
I do find the youth of today being a
little more sensitive to to people who
struggle or to people who are different
where you find anything I loved watching
the part where Joey's character Claire
gets embarrassed by her dad so your kids
ever felt embarrassed by their parents
or do you guys get the ultimate cool
card I don't think any parent gets the
ultimate cool card I'm sure there's tons
of stuff that both Reese and I do but
embarrass the kids I mean for instance
right now I'm shirtless on the cover of
a magazine I'm sure that's not my
daughter's favorite thing in the world
is it fun for you to read all the
comments about how much they look like
you and Reese I mean it's weird like you
know he looks oh she looks exactly like
her mother who else is she gonna look
like you type in their names in Google
or you type in your name and all the top
stories are oh look at look Elaine reser
look how much she looks like her dad but
I would it's I know it's an odd thing
that people fixate on that I wonder
sometimes like wow they feel about it we
talk about it too but I think we've all
made peace with the fact that we're out
there in the public
that people are gonna choose to key on
whatever is interesting to them we don't
sit around talking about how much we
look good look that's an interesting
point though cuz I never thought about
how it makes yeah cuz I see this
sometimes I'm and I feel like saying she
has her own face let her have her own
face
[Music]
you